how's it going guys Matt here with code
tag notorious we're going to do a video
on chat GPT now I'm sure you guys have
seen all you wanted to see about this at
this point every YouTuber and their mom
and their dad and their brother and
sister and their past relatives and
everyone from their history has made a
video on this because it's easy easy
click bait and the consensus seems to be
that it's basically Google maybe a
little bit better and it can also write
papers for you so you don't have to do
your schoolwork and that further
diminishes the point of school I guess
if you don't actually have to do the
work while you're going because you're
there to learn by doing the work why
make something that does the work for
you and accept anyway that's a whole
other ball game but uh
yeah I basically want to see if it can
actually help me solve real problems
that I have obviously if you ask it some
common question that's in an interview
It generally knows the answer to those
because it can Google them and figure it
out and if you ask it for some very
common thing to do with code it can
generally Google that and figure it out
well I'm saying Google I know I don't
know how it actually does behind the
scenes but basically if the answer is
somewhere out there on the internet chat
GPT seems to be seems to know about that
answer and can kind of award it to you
like a human that's basically what I've
taken away so far but here I am I'm
working on my little game here game
Library stuff and one of the things I'm
doing right now is I'm trying to cook
height Fields with Nvidia physics 4.2 so
that's kind of a big side point but I'm
wondering because this is sort of a
difficult thing to wrap your head around
and do I've got it like half done at
this point but I was wondering can chat
GPS
maybe help me because Nvidia
documentation's there there's some
samples and they're decent and they kind
of get it done they don't really uh get
it done quite right I have to abstract
some things and figure out some stuff
and let's just see all right so let's
see uh let's ask it full screen how do
you cook a
um let's see a model mesh and C plus
plus with Nvidia physics let's let's see
what it comes up with here all right to
cook it okay it goes pretty quick create
a cooking oh wow not bad
create a cooking object called yeah
wow I found this answer quick but this
is basically the answer from the
documentation so I'm not surprised and
this is probably somewhat a common
answer all right so we get cooking it
has kind of skipped over one thing I
know already yeah this is basically the
very
very much the default answer but are
also not bad not bad this is kind of
what I would expect to see it's actually
this was way easier than finding this on
Google and this was very quick so
basically on Google I had to sort
through like tons of nonsense stuff to
find this uh not tons but a few things
it wasn't quite this easy so this is
very nice to just see this all right so
let's read it from the top to cook a
model in C plus plus you need to use the
physics cooking Library here's a high
level overview now you do have to I
believe initialize physics in uh the
physics and some of it's common stuff
like the foundation so it skips over
that but maybe it assumes you know that
already I don't know but that's not too
bad so create a cooking object with the
PX create cooking this is correct yes uh
definitely I'm pretty sure you got to do
the foundation first all right well
we'll come to we'll come back to that so
maybe you know the goodness on the right
path but we do have to maybe do a little
bit of digging to know for sure whether
this will work
but it has skipped right to the cooking
where which is what I asked all right
load the mesh data from file or create
it programmatically the best status
should be a format that is supported by
the physics cooking Library such as
triangle mesh or convex Hull okay not
bad
um I think I'm using triangle mesh for
the most part and use the cooking object
to cook the mesh data this process
converts a mesh into a form that can be
used by the physics engine yes attach it
to a rigid body
let's see it doesn't do that in here
we'll get to that okay use the cook mesh
data to create a physics shape triangle
geometry or convex mesh geometry attach
it to a rigid body optionally you can
use the cooked mesh to create a visual
mesh for rendering purposes all right
here's an example let's see mesh
description if you fill the mesh
description with your vertex and input
data very good yep all right so this is
pretty good see I I think that this is
going to be a pretty good Aid to
programmers as far as getting stuff done
because often one of the one of the big
roadblocks for people is just finding
information that's correct enough like
when you're digging through
documentation you're always finding I
don't know if you're Googling problems
you're always finding like these 12 year
old stack Overflow answers that are just
complete completely riddled with
nonsense that doesn't help you I don't
know if you guys have the problem when I
had that problem it's like the top
answers are always 11 12 years old at
least it seems like I don't know why
that is exactly I don't know why Google
would put things that old at the top of
the results but it does it all the time
for C plus plus stuff and it's kind of
frustrating
and it's obviously useless data things
have changed most of the answers on
those are not very accurate and you
really got to like figure out a bunch
more but okay this is basically correct
though you just it did skip over
initializing physics I think that's the
big thing it missed here but hey let's
try this let's just copy this code boom
copied and let's go to to this I got
this little cooking
main so first we gotta do some stuff
um we can assume we need to but we need
to create all this stuff so we could
just do it I'm just going to do it in
the main
um I think I'm just gonna do it well the
tricky part there's a lot of there's a
lot of tricky parts to this we'll say it
doesn't tell you how to link the library
or set it up but you could probably ask
it that um I've already done it in the
cmake but let's let's just ask it let's
go uh let's say
I'll do you
um link physics 4.2 with
bcpkg and uh cmake on Windows see if it
comes up with an answer install vcpkg
very good yep install the physics
package very good yeah add the following
lines to your cmake include path this
that cmake fine package physics required
Target legal libraries private physics
physics uh I wish this were the case
it's not quite right and compile
definitions build your project okay so
the problem is this doesn't work at all
there is this this is completely like I
don't know unless I've updated it very
recently this simply this fine package
physics doesn't work at least in my
experience let me try it actually let's
just try it all right so I'm doing it
locally I'm doing a little differently
this is for like globally on your system
so the way the only way I could find to
do it was uh well yeah you got to put it
in your VC PKG Json this is for doing it
locally with your project the install
way that they showed was globally that's
fine actually but you can't just find
package physics you've got to do find
library with these hints for every
single different one so that's that's a
big difference uh but I don't know let's
try it let's go let's try this fine
physics required and Target link library
and get rid of all of these
and see if it's happy with that because
and you know I didn't find that to work
so
uh yeah let me just link a Target here
like this one here and uh we'll get rid
of all these okay so let's try it their
way with fine package and Target link
libraries and see what happens nope
can't find it so yeah this is what I ran
into as well so uh
now
to play The Other Side they did install
it differently they're not doing it with
this project based mode like this
installs it specifically for this
project not globally
um so maybe that's a little bit
different do we need to put config in
here will that make a difference
no
But ultimately yeah this is what I ran
into I thought what they said would be
accurate because that's what it seemed
to be but that
it might be close I'd have to try the
globally way the global way
um but in general no that didn't work I
had to do it this other way which does
work and I had to uh
there was there was no answer to this
like you can't find this online this
answer right here of how I had to do it
was is nowhere out there you basically
have to understand how find library
works and uh yeah you basically have to
understand how find library works and
deduce the answer yourself
so that was that was the reality of it
for me here so it does kind of make
sense to install such a large Library
like physics generally pretty large
globally uh with vcpkg and that's
generally the more accepted way of doing
it is to do it globally and not Project
based but I just like doing a project
based I I think it's better for shipping
than product
um but also
your results May Vary it's just the way
I like it so I will say not bad let's go
back to that
but not bad not bad if you're using it
it even gives you more of this ad
compiled definitions for PX
um C plus plus 11 or 14 and physics
Library should be linked with your
project okay so that's that's not bad
yeah
link to vcp eug's Tool chain file so if
we do all of this and we install
globally I would I would kind of expect
this to work but not bad let's see let's
ask the same question
um
how do you link as let's see same
question but we're going to add to it as
a manifest now on the Manifest okay
I don't know okay I guess we gotta start
over what new chat boom as a manifest
let's see okay I don't know it's broke
so does this happen to everybody okay
okay it's going to give us the same
answer I think let's see if it shows as
a manifest no this is not as a manifest
this is globally
slightly different answer they gave uh
the x64 and x86 and they put some
generator stuff in there and this time
their fine package has config on it for
some reason so a little bit of
difference different stuff
um
but that's not with a manifest because
the Manifest is this this Json right
here so they should say that you have to
create this file and add physics to the
dependencies that's what they should be
telling so they're getting close here
but
if it's anything like I experienced from
Googling the same question basically
this doesn't quite work because this
fine package doesn't work it'll it'll
just keep giving you the I can't find it
and you got to come up with your own
solution which ends up being this find
library so what I'm finding this is very
interesting uh overall I'm finding that
I'm running into the same problem I had
with Google and that's just basically
that nobody actually has the answer out
there so this thing doesn't have the
answer out there either
I don't know pretty interesting I guess
uh let's try something else let's say
um all right so one of the ways I'm
still messing with this let's say I'm
trying to get the vertices and indices
uh from a mesh out of asimp and pass
them into physics for baking all right
so what if we go uh get the vertices and
indices
of a model
or of a mono file or say 3D model file
into C plus plus code let's see what it
says here comes up with an answer pretty
quick use 3D modeling software export it
okay that's cool yeah that's so far so
good
says use tiny object loader that's good
or use SM
okay not bad
okay and then it tells you to use like
opengl or DirectX okay I've got a pretty
good General answer actually for that
quick question you know that's generally
the steps you would follow all right
it's also probably about the same thing
you'd get with Google if you
um
if you ask the same question on Google
so
I don't know but I think you guys
probably get the point at this point
it's it's pretty good but it runs into
somewhat the same problems that you have
when you Google the stuff whereas when
it doesn't quite work where you like
follow the steps exactly and then you
still get there's no package or whatever
on this step like how do you know what
to do next you don't and it's going to
be really hard to find it and basically
it's not gonna not gonna do this fine
Library thing
um
yeah I'll come up with some more stuff
to ask you here shortly I'm gonna do
some coding and I'll pop in and ask us
some questions here and there now I do
like that it saves on your account the
previous chats you've had so you can go
peruse over your answers this is way
better than like I don't know for me I
usually have a bunch of tabs open after
a while with somewhat links to my
different questions and stuff so it's
nice to be able to just pop over here
and be like oh what they say oh I can
just go look real quick so that's nice
okay it didn't really seem to you know
it told us how to initialize the cooking
stuff here but obviously this doesn't
work completely we need to fill out some
stuff uh like we need to initialize
physics foundation and that kind of
stuff so maybe we can ask it how to do
that how to initialize physics how to
initialize
physics 4.2
um
yeah we need the foundation object okay
then create physics
uh this has given us a Cuda contacts
manager and some basic tolerance scales
it's got a used Cuda Boolean optional
all right let's uh yeah let's just pop
this in here and see what happens now do
we want to use the Cuda stuff also why
does this include not working I think we
gotta regenerate some stuff here I know
some of you guys are going to complain
about my coding environment being white
but I find if I make it dark I can't
focus as well like I just focus better
with
the light background at least during the
day at night I like to turn it back to
dark but during the day when the Sun's
shining I'm going to bring a bright room
it's so much better when it's light but
it's getting late so I'm ready to turn
it to dark anyway so actually I switched
this quite frequently during the day
light background
all right cannot open source file well
it should be able to hear shortly once
we get this thing finished
all right but I have a feeling that this
is generally gonna be how it goes for
most stuff like you can get
a good sample of what the code might
look like but it's only like a starting
point so you're still going to have to
figure out like what not what do I need
to pass in here when should I be using
Cuda and how do I use Cuda um and a lot
of stuff like that so it's it's never
going to give us perfect answers it's
going to give us samples that could work
providing we could figure out the rest
and
you know that's not too bad I guess so I
guess the short answer there is
obviously this isn't going to replace
coders
um it's gonna it's just too much I think
there's a lot more it needs to learn
about how to you know with a lot of this
stuff there's just often prerequisites
that it doesn't quite address any how
could it this would you know this would
be a huge article to fully address all
this stuff so it's it's really good at
giving you quick answers and kind of
pointing you in the right direction but
I don't think it's ever going to write
code that unless you get lucky I guess
that that's going to work perfect for
your situation but I really like that
it's getting us in the right direction
quite quickly so I I think I'll find
this quite helpful along with my coding
stuff during the day and a lot of times
I'll probably use this over Google as
like I was complaining about earlier
Google just seems to give a lot of just
a lot of really bad results especially
when it starts parsing stack Overflow
and and maybe that's why chat GP is
actually
um a little better than Google because I
heard stack Overflow block chat GPT was
probably to their advantage stack
Overflow is just full of too many trolls
really to be that useful
is really the truth and and you know
it's really hard to manage there's to be
back on the topic of stack Overflow
versus this for a second there's a lot
of new people on stack Overflow that do
ask really ridiculous questions and they
kind of do need put in their place a
little bit I would say at least some of
them
but just the way that it's done is not
good it's way better to have an AI at
least be polite than some human just
spoo in there nonsense all the time at
you so I I do like this chat GPT I think
I think it gets a pass and that overall
it's pretty seems pretty good from what
I've experienced and seen so far it's
definitely definitely an advancement and
uh geez I'm just really glad that I
can't express how glad I am that stack
Overflow blocked it for their own sake
this would I think this would be a lot
worse if it were pulling from stack
Overflow I really do think that because
it's it's just hard to know what answers
from stack Overflow are actually good
most of the time too many trolls
anyway that's all speculation but uh
yeah I want to use this more and play
around with it more it does seem to be
somewhat useful for real work and you
know I think if you're deep in the
subject like if you're for example if I
was an expert with physics I probably
won't need much of this stuff but if I'm
just getting started with anything it
seems like it's pretty good at pointing
you in the right direction and really
getting you going at least with
at least so you don't stay stuck and at
least you know okay I don't understand
this I need to go read it sometimes it
provides you links which is super nice
why can't I pull these back up
it does crash some so that's kind of
annoying I seem to have lost these chats
all of a sudden for I don't know why
maybe I just need to refresh yeah okay
because like I might want to go back to
this and be like okay and ask follow-up
questions like extract
vertices and indices and extra cords
with essence
3D model file let's see what it comes up
with this and see if it uh you know
there's some answers out there yeah you
bring in the Importer scene post process
create the Importer object very nice
triangulate flip UVS that's debatable
whether you want to do that or not okay
iterate through the meshes very nice
yeah this is pretty good
it is probably just pulling this code
off of like uh learn opengl or something
or one of the
one of the sample code files in in SM
but still it's not too bad
it does in general give you the right
steps you got to go through all the all
the meshes and get all the stuff
now let's see
what it's doing here so for Loop so go
through a mesh for Loop through that
one's vertices faces texture chords now
it's not exactly okay yeah I think this
is telling you store the texture
coordinates in your own data structure
store in your own data structure and uh
that's that's fine that's generally what
people do I think that's mainly what I
do in my code except my code is a lot
more robust and goes through all sorts
of recursive stuff and does some special
caching things but still this would
basically get the job done as long as
you could figure out how to store in
your own structures which is really not
hard if you're half teasing with C plus
plus you could probably figure that out
but also it doesn't really go into
detail about when you would want to flip
UVS or not
um because I think it depends how you're
going to be rendering and uh yeah that's
not too bad it's not too bad overall I
would say this is good all right so I
also asked it when should I use Cuda for
physics cooking now I kind of already
knew the answer but I wanted to see how
it would respond and it basically gives
us a good answer that tells us what Cuda
is and it tells us that it uses the GPU
to perform highly paralyzable tasks or
much faster processing and it says it's
often used for cooking
process of pre-processing and optimizing
collusion geometry which is you know
probably what we want to do if we wanted
to go fast now we're going to pre-bake
in our situation so not necessarily
going to matter a ton but still be nice
might as well optimize it but you do
have to and it tells you you have to
have a Cuda enable GPU and now we can go
how do I use Cuda for physics
geometry cooking and see what it says
sure that you have the drivers you need
to have the tool kit very good and the
physics SDK installed right a Cuda
kernel function perform cooking on the
gpus function should take input geometry
as arguments and return the cook
geometry call it well it's getting way
ahead of me here but here we go it's
even given us some some decent code
called the kuna kernel function from
your C plus plus code
transfer data from GPU to CPU okay so
then it's given us some decent functions
so yeah this shouldn't this should give
me a good jump start on this whole
operation definitely going to be faster
than Google and it seems like so my
goodness I'm I'm just kind of falling in
love with this uh chat GPT at this point
it's it's I mean it's not the end-all
be-all or anything like that but it
definitely feels nicer than most Google
searches or search engine searches for
this coding stuff so I find that to be
pretty awesome all right let me know
what you guys think down below I
appreciate you guys and everyone who
supports me see you next one peace out